hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm going to be
reviewing the trailer today for a
special movie I've been actually really
anticipating Ted - I'm a big fan of the
first one I thought Mark Wahlberg was
great Seth MacFarlane has Ted is great
he followed it up with an incredible one
of the best comedies I've ever seen a
million ways to die in the West I mean
it it is one of the best it's pretty
awful see what they got in store happily
ever after only exist in fairy tales
yet of talking today is about to marry
his girlfriend I now pronounce you teddy
bear and wife mr. bear proving that
Americans don't give a crap about
anything so I got some big girls Tammy
wait and I are gonna have a baby that's
awesome me how do you guys we are we a
sperm donor who's that what were you
doing invited to it are you getting
ready what do you teach it way do your
hand I'm doing this for use when I get
in I can just bust it up what you think
you're a Red Lobster hey Johnny you did
it right there buddy catch what she took
somebody's kid
oh here we're gonna take a picture
posted on Facebook what hashtag your
Monday look at this it says if we want
to have a baby you're gonna have to keep
your a person in a four wall this is a
nightmare
we got fight for Gil lawyer it will sue
the government these civil rights I'm
Samantha Jackson must be ten uh yeah
Samantha Jackson what's your middle name
Leslie oh my god yes Sam L Jackson
that's great away just like Sam al
Jackson do listen you ever seen any
movie ever
he's the black guy can I do the same
rights as everybody else just because
you're different can you get me my life
back
do you believe you have a soul what did
you think I would do at this moment
objection overruled you know what to be
human in the eyes of the law the
important thing about being firm is
making a contribution to society
wait how's my coffee you're not building
Rockets figure it out with print 20
bucks I can toss a Cookie Crisp into
that guy's ass crack do it I'm gonna do
it sir I apologize for my five-year-old
child bad boy you'll sit there and eat
your fish nothing
you
ask you few test questions are you ready
yeah bring on do you consider yourself
to be human judge is the same no the
witness get it Oh rules I bought guilty
Achilles you're sick hey let's briefcase
for diving my chain stop beaver on the
witness I rest look at totally boys
looks okay looks alright I don't know it
I know it's a sequel and this is common
to say among see comedy sequels
especially but it doesn't feel that
fresh maybe Seth MacFarlane is looking
at you know go into that territory of
like political society humor a little
bit more but its execution you know it's
a green band trailer so I'm sure a red
band trailer would give us more of what
we want but this looks like a PG version
of what we got from the first head to be
honest I like where the trailer first
starts out where he's getting married at
Tammy or Tiffany I think it's Tammy and
he's getting married to her and Sam
Jones is marrying them so it's a cool
like hey remember the first one like
that was a good little nod and I like
the basic setup of Ted trying to have a
kid and so he's getting more Walbert to
be a sperm donor that moment where all
the sperm fell off Mark Wahlberg oh
that's pretty gross man that's like the
[ __ ] party on pornhub calm that I
will not watch there's something about
the plot of Ted having to you know prove
he has a soul you know he has to be a
human being in order to have a baby
there's something about that plot that
I'm not that really appeal to I would
rather see a movie that is just about
head trying to be a father or dealing
with a pregnant wife or something like
that rather than dealing with this the
whole idea is already ridiculous is
talking teddy bear with a foul mouth at
the same time like I think it'd be a
more interesting character dynamic
because what made the first tab works so
well was the buddy relationship the
buddy relationship between Mark Wahlberg
and Ted it seems really relaxed in this
one it doesn't seem like I liked how
things were at stake with Mark Wahlberg
and Mila Kunis's relationship and Ted
was an interference like there was a
more personal story to it this one
doesn't feel as personal and granted
it's like not like the deepest thing but
it's little things like that that made
Ted work so well was the heart of it
yeah it kind of looks like a kid's
comedy would random adult jokes like the
sperm and stuff it's just a trailer but
something about the way Mark Wahlberg
and Ted are interacting it kind of
reminds me of like when I saw Ocean's
Twelve like Ocean's eleven it was a cast
having fun but really committed to these
characters and then in Ocean's Twelve
they were kind of like yeah let's just
have fun and hang out on set and it kind
of looks like that
around like the adventure actually seems
kind of small doesn't seem as absurd you
know it like what I love about Ted is
the dialogue the back-and-forth the
crude humor of the banter and stuff I
feel like we're not really gonna get as
much of that in this one or it might not
be as good and what happened to Mila
Kunis I didn't hear anything about her
not being in this swear she she's hot to
look at if I get bored I can masturbate
to her where are you
Amanda Seyfried is she's good-looking
she know Mila Kunis hey yeah I mean I'll
wait for a red band trailer but either
way I'm gonna watch it I mean I [ __ ]
love the first one so much thanks guys
for telling me that trailer was out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the reel rejects and
transition to shout outs Damian Reeves
its Keanu Reeves is a black out of
wedlock child
dear Ryan I've been watching your videos
and they're very funny they make me
laugh so hard that milk went out of my
nose no semen you idiot also have a
youtube channel called Dam dam also like
you check it out if you got that and if
you to do a review on one of my short
videos but still talking when video is
still on if you can do that and the
picture I you see is the painting that
I'd done for senior year of high school
thanks man you rock in all of the real
rejects well your picture of senior high
school looks like you do a lot of
marijuana and if you do marijuana like
clapping out your channel as long as you
can hook up the bud my friend you can
tow Kat with me you got yourself a deal
I'll gladly review your channel send
over some weed sativa not indica I like
the mine high not the body high and if
you got some heroin that would be good
too
ace Vincent dela Cruz hey guys it's me
you know mark player one five zero one
Oh
can I please get a shout out pretty
please ace Vincent dela Cruz dude how
many Ace Ventura jokes were there about
you growing up alrighty then I'd like to
give you a shout out ace listen shout
out